let's go on out to medford oregon and
talk to travis travis what's going on
hey how you doing thanks for taking my
call you bet thanks for calling
how can we help well um i'm
recently engaged to my fiance chelsea
congratulations
yeah thank you guys and um she's
actually hopefully gonna get on this
call here but um
anyway we had a question trying to
navigate how to
combine finances um we're both on the
same page as far as combining our money
together
okay um i am self-employed
and the business requires
a substantial amount of money that kind
of stays within the business and i've
been paying myself out of that
previously and we're just trying to
figure out how the best way to
decide how much i mean do we pay
ourselves
on the personal side just trying to
figure out how to combine finances
but keeping the business what it needs
if that makes sense uh kind of it's kind
of a confusing way to ask it you
do you both work for the business or
just you uh just me she has a job
okay and so what do you pay yourself or
how do you pay yourself from your
business
uh basically what i've been doing up
until
uh until now is i pay myself twenty four
hundred dollars a month out of the
business to take care of
a home mortgage you know this the
personal finances
so would you is there any reason why you
would change that number that you've
been paying yourself
the the small amount of discussion that
we've had is we'd like to
basically figure out what we need
together for budget wise
and then if that number needs to change
it can we just we don't have a number in
mind but it's
is that a good way to even look at it
yeah sure i think you're just
overthinking it
yes i'm missing something i mean here's
the deal she's going to have a job yes
or no
yes and you have a job and so you pay
yourself in your job
so you guys just sit down and do your
budget what do we think i mean you you
are going to be moving into your house
is she going to move into your house i
mean what are we doing there do we know
uh we actually live together now um
so we're living in a house that i bought
years ago okay so just do the numbers
just do the numbers what is your budget
and now you have you've gone from one
income
to two incomes she's got some bills
maybe
but you guys combine everything yes you
should combine finances
and so you just do a budget and our
combined finances and if all of a sudden
let's say
for whatever reason i'm just doing this
for example purposes
let's say that she makes enough money to
where you only have to pay yourself 2
000 bucks a month
well that's 400 bucks a month that's
savings for your company
don't overthink it and and then vice
versa if the companies that
shed down some more money to make things
happen for each other then
goes the other way too sure you're in
charge it sounds like yeah you're giving
yourself a raise right
but are you
let me say it this way you all need to
have a combined personal income but you
need to have your business expenses
separate from your personal income
yes does that make sense and so can your
business afford your 24
000 year salary
um it can and it probably could afford
some more but the more i take
out of the business side the because
it's we've only been in business for
like four years so
we're in growth mode yeah great so only
pay yourself what you need
yeah again uh i love the question but uh
but this is pretty simple stuff
put your budget together and again if
you could pay yourself less
pay yourself less if you need to pay
yourself more pay yourself more but
get on the same page uh he you said at
the start of the phone call that they're
on the same page he said they're on the
same page so walk the baby steps out
together
right and don't live out of your it
sounds like you may be using your
business account as almost like a flex
spending account for your personal life
you pay your bills but if you need
something you'll just go grab it out
there
man you need to get on a budget on your
business
paying you your salary and then you need
to learn to live off that salary and you
need to ask yourself for a raise if you
need more money but don't be dipping
into your business just for when when
personal things show up that way that's
a good way to get yourself into some
trouble there